Remember that the best way to support the
David Pakman show podcast.
YouTube channel.
Radio show.
TV show.
Satellite TV show.
Twitch Channel.
Live streams and everything else is to become
a member at join Pacman dot com.
It's quick.
It's easy.
It feels good.
You can get the bonus show every single day
and you can use the coupon code 20/20 now
to save 66 percent off of the cost of a membership.
Consider it.
I'm inviting you go to join Pacman dot com
A we are going to go to the phone lines at
six one seven eight three zero forty seven
fifty and see what is on the minds of our
viewers and listeners.
Starting today with our caller from the six
to three area code who's calling today from
six to three.
Hello.
Yeah, that's you.
This is Ricky from Phenix.
Ricky, what's going on?
So I have two questions to ask you.
First would be about Kuhnen.
And I'm getting people to actually convert
from the conspiracy theory by your interviews,
really like you did.
I mean, I did one interview about it, but
it's not a topic I've talked about too much.
But that's helping people.
Yes.
So a lot of people on my Facebook posting
about, you know, like queuing on stuff.
Now, that's so.
And, you know, they're blaming Joe Biden for
some whatever reason, saying that he's a pedophile
or whatever.
So I have been you will I showed a video to
people about your interview, and then it's
kind of like converting it from believing
into that kind of stuff.
That's good.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
That's great news.
If that's.
Yes.
I like the.
Yes, because a lot of people don't want to
vote for Joe Biden because of the conspiracy
theory, so I'll say who knows if that's real
or not.
But let's face it, this did come from a what
did a right wing group.
So who knows if it's true or not.
And, you know, I don't want innocense.
We're in an election where, like, we could
go bad or go good.
Who knows?
Yeah, I'm just kind of like, you know, reconvert
people from big enough so we can actually
get a good spot for Abidin so we can at least,
like, you know, hold the bar and, you know,
go more left from there.
You know what I'm saying?
I, I completely know what you're saying and
I think you're doing exactly the right thing.
Now, Arizona, interestingly, it's not looking
so good for Donald Trump right now.
Yeah.
So I have been getting people are trying to
vote for Martelly as well.
Trying to get it blues so we can, you know,
get Martha McSally out.
So hopefully it does go blue for us in the
Senate.
It would be amazing.
I think, you know, my sense is if Arizona
does go blue, I think it's not going to be
a good night for Donald Trump nationally.
I think it's not just going to be Arizona
if it goes bad for Trump.
Yeah, I hope I hope no one gets out of office,
but I'm using your videos to actually, you
know, get you to vote for Biden.
You know, like I see your videos on Facebook.
I'll share it if and if I see anything that
could actually benefit people.
It's like no more vote.
Biden Like why it would be beneficial for
people.
I'll share your video.
Maybe that's why you're getting, you know,
one million subscribers.
You know what I'm saying?
Ricky, I think you are responsible for us
getting to a million subscribers.
Absolutely.
I think you are.
You are overwhelmingly the source of that.
And I really appreciate it.
Yeah.
So, yeah, I'm just trying to make sure, you
know, people make a better choice in terms
of this election because I don't want to make.
Well, you know.
Well, you get what I'm saying.
You know, I got to.
Hopefully we can.
Yeah.
But the second question is, how were other
ways I can get people to vote for Biden?
Because I get those people too far gone.
But there are people that are reluctant to
their vote or not vote.
Oh, right.
Yeah.
So, so.
So listen, don't try to argue with I think
arguing with Trump supporters is a much tougher
thing to do than just finding people who don't
like Trump, but who maybe may not be planning
to vote and explain to them Donald Trump is
going to claim that it was rigged.
We need every vote.
It's not enough for Joe Biden to win by 100
votes.
He needs to win by a million or ideally five
million or ideally seven million or whatever.
So.
So if there's ever an election that we need
every vote for, it's this one, because those
extra votes are what could be the difference
between Trump credibly saying it was rigged
and Trump not being believed when he says
it?
Yeah, no, I, I, I totally get you.
Yeah.
Because that's a bring about policy.
Like, you know, Biden wants to raise the minimum
wage to fifteen dollars.
That does catch a lot of people's eyes in
terms of voting for Biden, you know.
You know, I do I do use that tactic just like,
you know, raising the minimum wage is always
better health not it's not the best.
But you know better than nothing, you know.
I got your life right.
All right, Rick.
Great to hear from you.
You're doing great work down there in Arizona.
Keep it up.
Okay.
All right.
I know.
Thank you.
Thanks.
All right.
There's Ricky from Phenix doing all.
Doing it all.